when we begin this NewsHour in eastern
Libya where communities devastated by
the tsunami-like floods there are slowly
trying to recover Aid agencies have been
warning of a potential Health crisis
from water-borne diseases with unclaimed
bodies scattered under the debris and
washing up on shores search and rescue
teams in Donna have been working
non-stop the coastal city is
historically and culturally significant
it was one of Libya's wealthiest and was
home to at least 90 000 people before
these floods business from Port
operations kept that region active
despite Libya's nine-year conflict and
the city then had more than 4 300
buildings now much of it is in Ruins
well when storm Daniel ripped through
Downer on Monday it's too damn's best
unleashing nearly 30 million cubic
meters of water that's the equivalent of
12 000 Olympic-sized swimming pools it's
estimated that a quarter of the city
structures are now either partially or
completely destroyed their death toll is
in the several thousands Charles
Stratford begins our coverage
thousands of people are still missing
and feared dead
buried under the mud and Rubble or swept
out to sea
search and rescue efforts continue but
the chances of finding people trapped
and Alive are increasingly slim
that's why we are working as hard as we
can in these few hours that will have
safety margins to be able to locate
people alive and we're trying to squeeze
our dogs as much as possible to work on
those buildings that have been partially
destroyed and which have not been
completely submerged by the water
the wall of water carried many people
out to sea their bodies lie on beaches
having been washed ashore
this is the first time we see a disaster
as big as this in Libya we are facing
difficulties in the sea we are waiting
for the sea to calm down to be able to
see the bodies and try to retrieve them
survivors recount the terrifying moment
their loved ones were taken away
my life before was stable I had my house
and my family but now there is nothing
there's no life anymore
there is mounting fear of disease as the
hidden bodies decompose
we must be absolutely cautious and at
the same time act with total
responsibility in addressing the sources
of pollution from the dead bodies under
the debris to animals carcasses in
addition to any chemical materials
washed away by the floods
libyans from the west of the country
have driven across front lines
determined to help those in need in this
politically divided nation
but just getting the aid to where it's
needed most remains a huge challenge
security forces and the Army are doing
their best to restore the roads leading
into the city the catastrophe is massive
and as a result access to many areas is
not possible
foreign aid continues to arrive by air
but derna needs more International
assistance and fast we need the support
of International Community we need the
support of the UN agencies in order to
be able to manage this crisis in a
proper way
and to help libyans overcome this
unfortunate incident
survivors struggle to comprehend this
catastrophe clearing the modern debris
from what remains of their homes
and waiting for help
Charles Stafford Al Jazeera
well let's speak to our correspondent
resource order he is in the capital
Tripoli Russell can you give us an
update as to where we are with the
recovery operation now in derna I know
there's been talk of her potential full
evacuation
foreign
operations are still on the way but now
the main concern in the city of Darna is
the health issue because it is
deteriorating so rapidly and as days
have passed since the disaster now the
body is the dead bodies are decomposing
and that is posing a huge threat with an
experts to officials here are warning
that this could lead to an environmental
disaster that could cost many more lives
and today earlier today we have spoken
to the deputy the mayor of the city of
Darna Ahmed madrud and he said that
there are no expectations for the city
of dherna to be evacuated in
anticipation of a a spread of an
epidemic from the waterborne diseases
and now by every hour passing this is
becoming a real possibility here because
many people believe that this could be
the only way to avoid another disaster
however this is going to be a huge task
a very difficult task because just in
the city of Darna there are more than 30
000 people displaced and thousands of
the people are still searching for their
loved ones at least to have their their
bodies and much of the city is still not
even searched and checked so that's why
it's not easy to evacuate the city
that's hit by the disaster first also
there were the latest for us from the
Libyan Capital Tripoli thank you Russell
well let's bring in Georgette Ganon
she's the U.N humanitarian coordinator
in Libya she also joins us now from
Triple H thank you so much for your time
I know it's incredibly busy we know the
destruction stretches Beyond Diana we've
been hearing about ongoing power outages
blocked roads and I see from The un's
Flash appeal in albeda even the
emergency and ambulance headquarters
partially collapsed in suits the entire
city submerged in water are these areas
now getting help
yes they are in fact today we have a
team in Susa they arrived we also have a
team in albaida and they have brought in
some supplies and of course they're
there to see with local authorities with
the communities what else needs to be
brought in quickly to support the people
there
as you said we've been hearing a lot
about a potential Health crisis what are
your most pressing health concerns I
understand that the bodies aren't
potentially the biggest threat here
yes uh and you may have seen that the
World Health Organization and the
international Committee of the Red Cross
issued a statement about that today the
most important issue is the contaminated
water that water is contaminated from a
number of sources and that people are
not drinking tap water and that they
have uh potable water that they can
drink to avoid and prevent as the first
Speaker said waterborne diseases we
really want to prevent a secondary
Health crisis as we said we're going to
get into that in just a moment actually
with Margaret Harris from the World
Health Organization but for now let me
ask you about some of the less obvious
dangers too in the last hour I spoke to
the head of the Libyan delegation of the
icrc he was telling me about unexploded
Ordnance from the war now being
dislodged and lost there in the flood
water how real a threat is that in derna
well according to unmasked this is the
UN mine Action Center which works uh
with uh libmac the Libyan mine Action
Center this is a very real concern and
they are now planning to
uh come and try and do some uh tracking
and demining in the area when it's
possible but certainly there needs to be
a focus on this because of course it
presents a very serious Hazard not only
to the people who are still in the area
but to those uh who need to be there
rebuilding and of course the the aid
community and the First Responders as
was that we were hearing there from our
correspondent Russell that a full
evacuation of derna is being considered
that would be a huge operation I know
you're already supporting other smaller
evacuations would you have the capacity
to deal with something on that scale
well if the local authorities requested
support on that we would certainly
consider it uh and and we would discuss
with them how that could be done but any
type of evacuation would be based on
their request and then we would have to
really look at what the possibilities
are but of course if uh it's needed to
avoid widespread uh concerns in the
health area it needs to be considered
sure as Rosetta you are the U.N
humanitarian coordinator in the country
let me ask you this is a very divided
country you're dealing with two rival
administrations how has that been going
has there been coordination and beyond
that what is the mood like and the
conversation between these two rival
administrations as we deal with this
well our experience is that libyans from
all across the country at the local
level in the communities in the cities
have really come together in solidarity
and support of their their neighbors
their
their fellow libyans in uh in the
affected area
the authorities in all parts of the
country have come forward with support
with funding with supplies medical
supplies technical support these these
things have all been provided so what
we're seeing is a real effort to
um Provide support to the people
affected all across the country from all
libyans a real show of of national uh
support as Jose from what I had there it
sounds like people on the ground have
been coming together and we've certainly
seen that and at the upper levels of
government there's been provision of
resources but are they actually working
together is there The Hope potentially
that a crisis like this might be able to
to unify a divided country
well of course
we have been uh highlighting how
important it is that all people in the
country all the institutions the
political institutions
all the institutions really now work
together with a Unity of purpose which
is to support libyans in the affected
areas with recovery with rebuilding
their lives their livelihoods
and that is really what needs to be the
main focus at the moment at this very
important time
and that was rosette Ganon the U.N
humanitarian coordinator in Libya
Georgette thank you so much for your
time with us here on Al Jazeera and we
really wish you all the best with your
work going forward
well let's now bring in as promised Dr
Margaret Harris she's the spokeswoman
for the World Health Organization she
joins us now from Geneva Dr Harris as
we've been hearing these fears of
disease are mounting I know that the who
has been cautioning against Hasty
burials but there are also religious and
cultural preferences here too can you
explain your guidance
so the most important thing to
understand is that the bodies themselves
don't cause the epidemics the people who
died were healthy and they were killed
by a catastrophe so it's they're not
carrying any diseases that are likely to
cause an academic now bodies can the
contents of the gut can get into the
water but the water is polluted by many
many things it's polluted by a sewage by
all the damage and destruction so the
real problem here is that the water
can't be drunk and as as the resident
Court coordinator made it very clear the
big issue is to get clean Safe Drinking
Water because indeed if people don't get
that clean and safe drinking water they
will develop the many different
gastrointest intestinal diseases carried
by water and by food because they don't
have access to clean and safe water and
food well let me ask you about that
because we have heard these calls for
people to not drink the water to rather
drink treated or bottled water but is
there actually access to that on the
ground
well that's one of the things that all
the humanitarian efforts are really
really
um racing to provide because that's
number one clean water well shelter
clean water and of course health care
that's the other thing that we are
really working to get all that as close
to people where they are as quickly as
possible Margaret we've been hearing
from doctors in derna that they are
worried about the bodies becoming a
source of contamination I see that the
who is saying that if common precautions
are taken with the body is that the
disease of the risk of disease is then
low but are these common precautions
possible there's obviously little if any
electricity so no-called storage
presumably not even enough body bags and
the bodies are still lying there in the
sun is none of that a worry
so of course and you know it's so
distressing for people to see this is
horrific but remember each one of those
bodies with somebody's father mother
child there's a family that doesn't
necessarily know what happened to them
they're a social and legal requirements
so pushing and rushing to just dispose
of people as if they are now a threat
causes greater harm in the long term
sure and obviously there are some
religious and cultural um preferences
there in in some Islamic cultures you
want to bury people closer to their
death and obviously there are logistical
constraints around that let me ask you
just a little bit more about this water
contamination because we've we've been
worried about the fecal matter
potentially that have been left from
bodies that what's in their in their
stomachs as you suggested are there
other things that worries you about
about what's in that water
oh absolutely when you've had buildings
destroyed and you've had water rushing
through all the chemicals all the all
the different things that are in
buildings will pollute the water and
again sewerage systems have been
destroyed as everything's broken so
you've already got the sewage and indeed
um our sewage carries a lot of viruses
and bacteria that you certainly should
not do not want to be drinking of course
there has been talk I believe of a
cholera vaccination program how's that
begun
so we're we're ramping up and looking at
all kinds of vaccination programs and
we're looking very much at the one of
the other critical things is to get the
child vaccination programs
um strengthened so to make sure that
children get vaccinated against measles
and those other things and that sounds
strange but that's critical again you've
got children in poor condition cramped
together if you get a measles outbreak
that could lead to a terrific rate of um
thickness and deaths Donna's Deputy
Mayor as we've been hearing is saying
that they're considering a full
evacuation of the city would you support
that idea or is that then just
relocating many of the same health
challenges elsewhere
our focus is really to get the things
that will protect people to them where
they are so the Clean Water the medical
services the medical supplies the
expertise
get them to people so that they can
start to rebuild they can live safely
and protect themselves is what we would
like to see happen Dr Margaret Harris
there the spokeswoman for the World
Health Organization speaking to us from
Geneva thank you so much for joining us
Dr Harris and thank you for your time
and we wish your teams all the best on
there on the ground